but uh one one question is that we were
discussing on the last podcast was um
well nico was saying one thing and i was
saying something slightly different but
in a way we were both speaking about
something that's relatively true because
nico was saying
how
social media platforms are private
companies and therefore they can make
their own decisions when it comes to
things like how much
sort of diversity of thought and speech
they would like to have on their
platform this is based off spotify and
rogue it was kind of inspired by that
yeah is matt joining us or no no no
um
but then i was gonna play smash brothers
but then i was saying well yes
that's true but also
you know they've sort of like
gone beyond that
and
then the question kind of comes down to
like okay so have have they gone beyond
that to such a point where like they are
now public speech platforms in the sense
that
there needs to be this this sort of
access to like open discussion
and and and obviously the counterpoint
to that is like well what about like
egregious
wrong
information
and obviously the free speech argument
is like well
most people are smart enough to see that
that's stupid right
but then the counterpoint is to that is
like well
yeah but if you're
now you have a microphone now you're not
just standing on a soapbox in a public
square being like oh that guy's nuts
you know now you're like
now you're able to figure out all the
all the other people who are nuts too
and band them together and then after
and once you're getting enough people
together then it doesn't seem so nuts
you know
and so
it's like
there's this very delicate
idea which is like well how do you how
do you engage in
like civic dialogue that actually brings
valid ideas to the center
of the conversation
so that people can figure out what's
best
about any topic
how do you do that without how do you do
that with censorship how do you do that
with censorship i don't know how you do
how do you do that
that's what we were talking about yeah
we've been wrong
so we don't have to we don't have to do
this topic but that's i just figured we
would roll on it to to well did you hear
about the
what what i forgot the other streaming
company that offered him another deal oh
somebody offered rogan another deal yeah
so they're like hey well we will give
you a hundred more million dollars over
four years if you come to our
little streaming platform
and we're not going to censor you there
right right i mean right well spotify is
not censoring me there no yeah yeah but
like apparently you know there's outrage
they took down his episodes yeah even
though
i don't know if they did it just makes
me tired yeah yeah talking about it
because it's like look i don't think
it's good to say the n word no one no
one does well this this was before that
the conversation
and then basically after the covet stuff
there people were like all right boys
get your
archaeology tools out we're going
through everything he's everywhere
we should we should bring that up
because like there was a very obvious
like hey somebody went through
everything he's ever said with a
fine-toothed comb and cut together all
the n-words now obviously i think it
doesn't even need to be said
no everyone agrees like
not a good look right to use that kind
of in any context
right but like still you also have to
consider like the way and the
sensitivity that people are towards that
now
is way more than it was 10 years ago
like let's be honest i mean it was quite
quite people were quite sensitive about
using racial slurs ten years ago no i
know but
at least you there was there was
there was some ability to use it within
context but even eminent made that joke
like
in one of his songs right he's got that
lyric i mean that you'd want to mess me
up for saying the word yeah but i mean
to do the truth of it is that it doesn't
matter right you know it's like i'm
sorry yeah is it a bad look absolutely
but like
you know i've listened to some his
podcast on and off for like the last
four or five years myself
totally obviously he's not a racist no
obviously not like it's like it's like
it's like is that a stupid joke to make
yeah of course it is
is it embarrassing to have someone make
a super cut of all your embarrassing
moments absolutely
right so you know i don't know it's like
it's just obvious that somebody was like
okay let's do it let's do a hit piece
yeah i know it's it's that yeah that's
the sad thing about it is it's like if
you've ever actually taken the time
to listen to conversations that he has
with people i mean i listen to
just by way of comparison like the
sanjay gupta episode with compared to
like the robert malone episode they
obviously have super different opinions
on how to deal with kovid and how it
should be approached
but rogan sat there and listened to both
of them and had interesting
questions to both of them and wasn't
like
yeah and he even says that himself he's
just trying to have conversations with
people
from interesting walks of life who bring
something to the table
and like to to to to want to censor
somebody because the the people that
they bring to that table you don't agree
with obviously is wrong
well i mean he doesn't like vaccines i
guess
no he that's not true at all
well he he specifically doesn't like
code vaccines no in his no that's the
again this is like
it right but that doesn't mean he
doesn't like them or in his sanjay gupta
episode he specifically goes over this
like they get into this exact thing
which and he says in that episode very
specifically there's a very specific
reason why i don't i d he didn't have
one and he was actually talking with him
about hey what are the merits of
of it and they went over data and all
that stuff and he
again like
he was he was saying he didn't get one
because he was about to get one and then
two people that he knew one of them had
a stroke and like the other one had a
heart attack
so he was like what's going on here this
is weird so then he looked into some
data then he got covid
and then
got healthy yeah we threw down the four
grand for the antibodies you know which
did the job what do you mean
you know like so you and when you get
coveted yeah you can either like you
know take tylenol right or slap down a
few grand and basically get
an antibody yeah
basically cure you instantly
right and so he did that right yeah
that's that's what like trump did right
you know that's what every every every
horror story you heard about cobid where
everyone was like yeah trump got covered
hell yeah he's gonna die you know he's
like
a couple thousand bucks got some
antibodies he's fine yeah yeah i heard
him going on about that obviously it was
just hilarious how it's like it's a
treatment and then it's like
i don't know it's it's it's just
hilarious but both both gupta robert
malone and the other guy that he had on
who was very controversial about all
that
all were like hey those monoclonal
antibodies are actually really good for
getting over it yeah of course of course
it is i mean i don't know again i'm not
trying to get into that dude i just i
just was so done with this cove and [ __ ]
code's dumb
and honestly like yeah stats are crazy
and all but from my personal experience
it's completely overrated
yeah so i'm just saying that like i i've
had it my whole family's had
family fine they're good like they all
got covered and like it was
like nothing it was nothing every cold
the kids got last year was at least
twice his worst
uh twice as worse as that yeah um but
this is what this is what goes to the
heart of it is like you you know you you
you go oh well judging by the fact that
he's not vaccinated he probably doesn't
like the cove vaccine or what somebody
said about him but this is the exact
part of the conversation that he was
getting into and i don't need to
reiterate that if you obviously if you
want to listen to him you know but this
is the thing it's like dude like yeah
there's like there is the cdc there's a
gun there's stats and stuff but
ultimately like you know your personal
experience is far stronger as far as how
you
you know make decisions
than
you know
effectively the message you know the the
guidelines and all that stuff because at
this point it's like it's like i feel
like i'm an anti-massacre at this point
it's just like someone's like wear a
mask i'm like
no
no like i why why why should i have to
wear a freaking mask anywhere or even
presented a vaccination sam it slows
down the spread it slows down the spread
but we're at this point where like
everyone gets it and it doesn't even
matter
right yeah no hello everybody welcome
back to that point in the podcast where
i tell you about today's sponsor now
storyblocks is today's sponsor so huge
thank you to them for always sponsoring
this podcast because they literally help
us make it possible they also offer a
great service that we use here at
corridor digital it's the one stop shop
for all of our stock asset needs and it
can be your one-stop shop too you see
we're constantly in need of high quality
4k b-roll audio images motion graphics
after effects templates and more and
where do we go we go to story blocks in
order to get those things and the best
part is they have flexible subscription
plans depending on your budget but with
the unlimited all access plan which is
the one we have here you're able to
download as much as you want from the
site and use it in whatever you want
royalty free it's a brilliant solution i
remember back in the day we had other
options for stock assets and you had to
pay per download or you had to pay
different license fees depending on how
you were going to use it storyblocks has
done away with all that and they said
guys look let's just keep it super
simple pay us the subscription fee get
as much as you want whenever you need it
and we will constantly be updating our
library all the time so that you're
getting something new every time you're
on the site it's a great service it's
something we use every day and you can
get started today by going to
storyblocks.com corridor cast or click
the link in the description below that's
storyblocks.comcast to get started and
once again huge thanks to them for
sponsoring and now let's get back to the
episode and see what sam's going to say
next
whatever anyways no one here's the thing
here's here's the ultimate thing here's
the lesson no one gives a crap about
this and we should totally change topics
people like this is another
tired yeah no i wasn't trying to get
into covid i literally started this off
on the tangent of like talking about
free speech on public platforms and
whether you guys wanted to discuss that
um i was just presenting it as an idea i
think to answer your question the only
way to make it work is that have every
opinion should we make it or allow every
opinion on your platform should we make
you can't just say that opinion isn't
allowed or else
well that's what i'm saying that's see
this is this is the crux of the
situation and it's like again not
everyone has to listen to that thing
it's like if it's really absolutely like
hopefully
the extreme opinions people aren't
listening to
but i'll just at the same time like
can you really
put those kind of
and i'm not just saying like can you
censor it obviously you can censor it
i'm saying
can you really expect people to not
like find
extreme opinions
instead you need to be relying on like
people's ability to be smart enough to
like
see
the ones that are valuable
and the only way that that happens is by
allowing people to talk
yeah i yeah it just comes down to this
like i think that the main issue is that
people like there's a lot of topics that
have shades of gray
and very frequently
it's
i guess people just get this feeling
that where it's like look yeah there's
many sides to this conversation
but in the interest of
i guess
i don't know
get a fast resolution basically
there's like a one big decision made
about it about what you can talk about
or how you can discuss things yeah and
they're like look if you're deviating
from that then technically it's like
worth censoring even though it's like
all right here's this larger
conversation
right so in so in context i'm not i'm
not talking about covid issues here i'm
talking about this as an example sure
right like the the example of
discussing
alternative treatments
versus just
and only
discussing a vaccine
yeah as an example yes that is one
perfect example it's like
yeah but discussing anything outside of
nope vaccines are the only thing we we
need to be doing and that's the thing
that we need to do and nobody gets to
say anything else that's to the point
where it's like whoa
what why that's so weird it is weird
that that that that would be like the
only
thing allowed it's in the past though
that isn't that great doesn't that feel
great to know that this is all behind us
finally that's fine
but just you know no i i i i i agree
yeah like i agree i just it's like it
feels so trivial where it's like we're
gonna ban joe rogan for covered
misinformation it's like what like i'm
not does that matter anymore like well
it does cover this information matters
in the sense that people are still dying
like i had a friend who lost two
grandparents in a week people are still
dying yeah obviously so people will
continue to
indefinitely but but i just don't get
how we can stop it like
you know it's like it's just it's a
thing that exists now
and there's vaccines and
there's known methods of being protected
and you know sometimes they work and
sometimes they don't and like
unfortunately the only way to really
prevent it is just to live in a hole and
close the door right you know so you
took the answer out of my mouth i was
just gonna say dig a hole dig a hole
like and it's it sucks it freaking sucks
it's not it's not i'm not saying it's a
good thing my my concern on is on the
free speech side of this okay because
because if you
if you
don't allow
the the conversation around like this
guy's talking this guy's having
known experts talk about alternative
methods to
treatment
we need to
kick him off the platform for that sure
like
that's weird that's super weird and i
just what i don't get though is
shoot dude it's a rabbit hole it's like
truly truly where did this start
where oh here we go
where did we talk about it nobody knows
controversial there's there's even the
cia acknowledges that there's evidence
that it started in the lab are we no no
no no no no no i'm talking about this
con the concept of modern day
misinformation oh like that recalling
your earliest memories right you know
like are we talking about obama's birth
certificate kind of stuff
is not the first misinformation ever
like how the birther movement how far
back yes i love you start rolling this
back here
yeah to like okay because what you know
before you know obama we had bush this
has been going on since time immemorial
since humans could tell lies about each
other i know you're awake going on
there's always been missing
and let me say it's been a lot worse
than it is now i know things seem
a lot worse the thing is like that's a
great point we have a lot more to weigh
in balance even those of us who are very
polarized yeah
there's many situations in history where
misinformation did a lot more damage
quite a bit yeah quite a bit we don't
need one german guy like right yeah
that's just the most recent example
that's right yeah i mean most recent
example within the last 80 years site a
site
site exhibit a but also that has been
going on look at china right now i mean
right what's going on right they're
muslim populations right yeah what the
british said about us way back in the
day oh dude
don't get me started
don't get me started on the stamp act oh
dude wait
wait have i talked about the tea party
fun facts where i think
meant just liquor
because like tea time was inexchangeable
an exchangeable term for
drinking a meal yeah at a certain point
in time so like you can say the tea
boston tea party was about sure throwing
tea into the uh ocean but it was also
because they were raising alcohol taxes
or specifically like rum
that was uh
that was coming from closer to the
americas was being taxed more
yeah and so that that actually was
enacted like two or three years before
the tea party but yes that was the tea
party itself was the response to
yeah so there's a few things stuff like
that there was a few things that that
led to that and that that was one of
them this is a total tangent
in the comments who's like
correcting us on our obvious
lack of knowledge on some of this stuff
we're just talking i mean some
corrections that's fine corrections are
welcome
not like
down trotting us participate
participation is welcome yes thank you
so much because everyone else is
listening to be able to just kind of
look down and go oh thanks yeah your
footnotes are very encouraging we'll say
asterisks every time we wanna we wanna
look down for a footnote and you can
just add it in there first okay so the
tea party
so the first they had the stamp act and
then people got all up in arms about
that literally up in arms and then they
were like well okay maybe and then they
kind of repealed it for a little while
and then they were like okay well how
about this we'll just charge tax on
stuff that's not
from britain
and so then they started charging tax on
like non-british colony rum
and stuff and but then the colonists
were like well wait but this guy's way
closer and he can get it to me for
cheaper and then i can make more profit
like why do i have to buy it from you
that was literally the thing it's just
like it's like yeah the carrots you grow
in your backyard get taxed right but the
ones we send across an ocean won't be so
that way that way the prices are even
yeah
that's what happened i know it's
literally dumb yeah it's literally dumb
and then well not to mention the the
the
uh
approach of the
king and his court like the approach
that they took
was like
very incompetent like it was it was
he was sending these people there were
people were making decisions who had
never even been to the colonies like who
didn't had no involvement in it and they
were just considered to be like this
sort of backwater
of
like i mean it was the largest colony
that they had but in terms of like
america yes but in terms of but in terms
of like being equivalent to an english
citizen who has rights in parliament
like you know like sorry that's that's a
different
colonies yeah yeah i mean the british
were just kind of so full of themselves
they were they they no offense scott we
love you no i mean look this is the
british of it's just 300 years ago 300
years ago it's fascinating i mean being
at the head of a you know global empire
will will do that do that for a couple
hundred years yeah wait i have an idea
can i can i kind of i'm gonna i'm gonna
loop back to people and they were an
amazing society like some of the things
that they did and discovered and like
invented and and their system of law by
the way the system of like how they were
able to peacefully transition from a
pure monarchy over the course of
hundreds of years to two houses of
legislature one's a lower house one's
upper house and to balance that like a
bike the concept of a bicameral
legislature with balanced common law and
then balancing that with the executor
that they all came up they came up with
that
it's freaking it's a freaking incredible
form of governance dude i love watching
british politics because they just yell
at each other it's so great and that's
probably why it works because they get
all their aggression out yeah you know
and then they don't like take it to the
battlefield that's the common law yeah
but no um you want to hear a really
funny idea for a crew video all right
sure yes so we made a time capsule all
right yeah
so we made the time capsule we
put it in a microwave and bury it in the
backyard i did it but i'm being inspired
from this joe rogan thing still works
i'm thinking
we do like uh it's more of like a uh
blackmail capsule
where we basically all like blackmail
secrets we write one script yeah that
has like every offensive thing you could
ever say in it yeah and we all
take an sd card and put into a camera
and record ourselves saying the script
it's the blackmail and then we remove
the sd card no one has to see it we all
put this into uh like a microwave
this is like another microwave
microwave next to it this is like a
social media blood blood oath and then
10 years later well no i mean i mean
depend we'll make an agreement or
contract which says something about like
how what are the terms of unveiling this
yeah this horrible
horrible bag of sd cards in a microwave
wow
so it's a good one it's like a self it's
like an auto canceler
it's like self if self
if you're listening to this offensive
message that means i am no longer
[Laughter]
i love that
yeah i mean they're not gonna give a
crap back then that's like
that's like someone from
the revolution you know being like well
king georgie's not that bad you know and
we'd be like oh that's interesting yeah
probably has some some uh
some british
roots i guess but i don't know
what what gets me is like
how much of a shitster george washington
was and like when you think about it i
think a lot of it goes down to
that guy so he started the seven years
award by the way yeah which is like a
big [ __ ] deal like
he
he preemptively basically attacked a
french
patrol yeah all right they shot first
they weren't supposed to he was just
supposed to like tell him to leave yeah
and said they ambushed this french
patrol like out of nowhere
during like this really tense part of
like um
history where like things were really
tense
so i mean he was the spark basically
yeah he was in command like that was his
first like or one of his early commands
yeah and because of that there's a
theory i love which is like because of
the um he he was very salty and
because they wouldn't promote him
because they're like oh this freaking
start washington this colonist like you
know
and like
no one took him seriously across the
pond and do you think he was just angry
so it's like well i'll start my own
country and i'll be the president maybe
maybe there's there's like something to
it though i mean i agree that would make
total sense like how much of an [ __ ]
do you have to be
to like basically start a war like that
and then
create a country
i mean look all all great people in
history
today right now
but seriously
think about it like you're like oh man
traffic today i'm a grump and like who's
the guy who gets a bulldozer right and
[ __ ] drives it but that's not exactly
that's not exactly an analogous
to it's not exactly what's going on at
the time it like to the it's it's all
about that confidence and taking an
extreme act and be willing to stand in
the front yeah you know it's like you
and on shaman level kind of confidence
you also have to consider like the the
level of the level of invasiveness that
they considered to be
offensive without any ability to make a
recompense in parliament
was the main problem and you got to
think about it this way
these people came over here
when literally it was like you're going
to the new world dude
i probably would never see you again
because you're probably going to die
yeah it was like that's a penal it was
like yo you're a protestant or whatever
get out go why no and then they and then
they separated into their own the reason
why the colonies sort of started was
because well first of all a you had like
the the idea of people coming over here
in like
almost for like business purposes it's
like hey we found some land over there
does anyone want to get an exposition
together an expedition together and go
settle it and come up with come up with
profits for the crown we'll let you
basically do whatever you want as long
as you pay us and a bunch of people
tried this from religious organizations
and other people and they spread out all
over the colonies and like how maryland
was different from boston and how boston
was different from the south and they
all had their own like protestantism
going on some were congregationalists
and some were like
others and so
but those people came over and were like
hey so we're used to the last 300 years
of basically being able to do whatever
we want and exclude whoever we want and
not have
anybody from the british government come
in here and tell us what to do so if
you're going to ask us
to pay you tax
then you need to give us representation
and then and then that literally that
tiny issue that tiny issue
became became all these other things it
led into all these other things oh yeah
and then once once they were like wait
you want to be rep wait are you trying
to pull away don't don't pull away from
us colonies hold on and then and then
they became more paranoid and then
because the crown got more paranoid then
the colonists became more paranoid and
then they kept asking
different things of each other that's
exactly what happened with texas and the
mexicans as well
because texas was like the texas became
its own country for a while and that was
exactly how that went down too it was
like two different cultures clashing
that would never understand each other
yeah well i don't know i mean i kind of
but it's it's still like i mean
obviously there's tons of historical
things is a huge issue there's so many
variables here but you know it's still
like
you're thinking about the situation all
right let's say there's someone you're
having a heated disagreement with all
right and you're fundamentally
disagreeing on something
and it goes down to the terms of like
look
i'm gonna step back and then but then
they step forwards again and it's like
yeah it's not you're not you're
defending yourself necessarily because
your your opponent hasn't thrown a punch
yet yeah but you you start to get to
that point of like all right well i have
to set the terms which is please take
one more step forward
i will throw the first punch yeah which
normally you're like oh yeah
america the colonists defending
themselves you know so to speak it's
like no it's not like the british came
and started like
started like a full-on war by just all
right we're gonna shoot everyone here no
of course not it's like the colonists
were like you take one more step and
we'll start then we shoot first
and so they someone had to have the
balls of going like
start shooting totally you know
which is that like i just wanted one in
context like george washington just like
he shot first at the french and he
sharked off yeah like it's a little
confident but imagine
that it sounds like now but imagine i
mean but you're it's that type of person
imagine that george washington's
[Music]
it's modern day right okay
and
a new moon
is discovered
this sounds awesome no i know but like
okay
a new moon is discovered we couldn't see
it for some reason but it's there it was
behind the other it was behind the other
moon okay yeah it was always on the dark
side of the moon that's why we never saw
it
is actually great starting for a sci-fi
novel so and then all of a sudden the
other
the united states government is like hey
does anyone want to go colonize the moon
we can't really help you do it but if
you do it and you swear fealty to the
united states
while you're up there
then
we will
you know
you'll be our
it'll be ours yeah and and you'll reap
the best little buddies yeah i mean
you're going there and
and it's a hell hole and there's it's
dangerous everywhere and there's
martians up there who have been there
long before you who don't like you
of aliens yeah yeah and and or martians
i guess aliens yeah
moons
and then this is exactly what happened
and then all of a sudden
the us government sends a ship up there
and they're like okay now you need to
pay us some tax because now that you
have a colony established and you're
like wait a minute i established this
whole colony myself and they're like
yeah i know but you need to pay us now
because you did it with our foreign off
the moon yeah we're gonna tax you more
than just the rocks we can ship but
you're not an american citizen you're a
loonite
yeah and so you don't and you're like
well do what can i get they're like no
you don't have any representatives you
don't have any of that you just stay
there no you're just describing and you
pay however you want to pay us
or you you you pay us whatever we decide
you pay us and and in our one penny per
stamp
this this analogy is way too close to
the subject we're talking about no no
well sorry there's a lunatic named
schmorge washington
washington and he happened it's just
sometimes it's hard for people to put
things into context when they happen so
many hundreds of years ago but like
you gotta you know who shoots the lasers
first
dude
you're like you send one more spaceship
here trying to take our moon rocks right
attacks our rocks we're gonna we'll
shoot lasers if you land that ship right
and then schmorge washington it's like
yep shoot the lasers and the out lunar
congress and that shows
the right spaceship first
and omega alpha yeah
yeah kicked it all off the battle of
thorax
actual martians yeah you know what is
funny about revolutionary war
and almost any other numbers before that
so
i re-listened to that dan carlin podcast
about the celtic invasion oh yeah with
caesar yeah
and
then obviously the numbers who knows
what the real numbers were but the
numbers in the revolutionary war were
like so small even compared to the civil
war and then especially compared to
world war one and world war two oh yeah
people like thousands of troops not like
hundreds of thousands like it was just
like oh yeah
when the uh
continental forces
sieged yorktown which was like in 1781
which is like the last big battle of the
war where uh what was his name
cornwallis gave up
they had like 10 000 guys
at like that was like a lot that was
every yeah that was like everyone that
they could muster right and there was
like a point like i think in like the
late
the late
part of
1777 or six it was like right after when
washington was in a bad way yeah he had
like 500 guys because everyone was like
[ __ ] or they died or they're like [ __ ]
this right i'm going home
and then
um you know finally they were able to
recruit more people but like it wasn't
looking good for a long time no the the
incompetence of the british generals
actually did a lot for i guess they're
used to taking their little boats and
making a little blockade or whatever
right and they're like yeah the blockade
will fix it
you know they did that i mean
i know there's a nation of island
warfare
and they have this huge continent
[Laughter]
like how are we supposed to serve these
boats barely
yeah
we can barely penetrate this continent
with our ships sir
so it brings up a good point though this
moon thing because like back to what we
were talking about yeah
and there's that that movie don't look
up is also really cool yeah i haven't
seen that yet but it's so funny it's
very on the nose it's very like too soon
but very good yeah like well-made
well-acted um
but like the fact that like okay say
there was a new moon discovered behind
the old moon right and we can't see it
right we know it's there because there's
a moon guy came down right
if if joe rogan was the first one to
interview the moon guy do you think
people would believe him no yeah well
some people would but others wouldn't
then it would be politicized right
because well exactly a new mooner
exactly and so how do we like the moon
even real like i've never been there we
need that discourse though you need the
discourse i think that if you have a
strong opinion you should always look
into the other opinion not just block it
out and say you know anyone who believes
this is dumb or like dangerous
and like if your opinion's really good
then it will hold well the truth the
truth will will bubble to the top like
one which is actually functional
yeah yeah that's weird
it's weird how that works how not
everything is yeah not everything is
broken down into one spectrum yeah
yeah man that can be used everyone right
now it's just i can't i can't do it man
i can't i tune it out i think people are
starting to get sick of it honestly
which is why i kind of wanted to have
this conversation because i've noticed
like over the last with everything
that's gone on the last two years people
are starting to get like people are
really starting to get tuned in to oh
you know i i heard people say that there
were people who were just looking to
take advantage of me
but now i really see it
clearly yeah hey you guys want to like
really uh take a right turn and have a
fun little like uh yes end of episode
thing all right yes let's talk do we
have to
this one's a hoot have you guys
seen the
nominations for the oscars this year no
no
it is
so dumb what
oscars
2022
i don't want to say fuming but like my
eyes rolled back into the back of my
head all right best picture all right so
okay let's
what awesome movies have we seen this
year that you think would be nominated
for for something like dune dune what do
you think it's nominated for
that's picture
picture
it's got nominated i think it's uh maybe
maybe costume cinematography maybe uh
cinematography dune got that yeah and
production design yeah so cinematography
and what about vfx dune yes we got so
dune
how funny it's a movie that's a good
movie
it happens to have great achievements
across the board and is recognized
in those categories yeah all right is
there a great movie you've seen this
movie
is there a great movie you saw over the
last year matrix resurrection of course
okay obviously that's nothing there's
nothing there okay
yeah obviously it didn't get nominated
for anything anyways uh that's the
effects no uh okay how about spider-man
no way home
yeah yeah no i said spider-man
like our vfx okay okay that's it
that's all
that's it this is like oh yeah it's like
oh two years of no box office sales yeah
it storms in it's a great film it's
amazing
uh it revitalizes the movie industry and
gives it the kick start to break it out
of coping makes a billion dollars yeah
they're like no the vfx were alright
okay i haven't seen it yet it's
incredible it's incredible it is
absolutely incredible and the fact that
it's like
like how can you do that
so so how can you do that wait what else
is it what is it
let's go over that's nominated is it a
bunch of indie films
picture best picture all right wait no
offense but before you say that remember
when they gave the movie with casey
affleck best picture oh manchester
united
by the scene
don't get me wrong it was a good that
sounds pronounced it was a good
performance
but like it was more crying was it best
picture
best picture oh no he didn't make it
wasn't best actually
i think he won best actor look look
listen to this look at this dumb [ __ ]
sorry belfast best picture belfast coda
don't look up drive my car dune king
richard licorice pizza nightmare alley
and power of the dog everyone says power
that august is kind of good it's pretty
good wait a minute i thought it was king
king richard is not is about will smith
being that's not the last serena
william's dad or something the last duel
that is no there's no no recognition of
the last dude not anywhere anywhere
which is really sad because that was the
coolest movie other than spider-man i
saw last year it did have amazing
production design it was a good story
it's a really good script yeah it was an
original screenplay too it was like
obviously based on
story crazy yes based on like true stuff
but created great
it's an actual original movie that you
know technically
it was good man it was really good it
was there was not a moment in there
where i wasn't like completely in the
world that they had built yeah and like
what's nightmare alley is that's the
thing that's the deltoro's newest one
which i heard mixed things about but i
have not seen it i'm sorry but the last
one was like shape of water still right
right i don't know
exactly
what followed but the shape of water won
best picture and that was the dumbest
dumpster fire i've ever seen
who loves to have sex with this fish
monster
and
the whole cross is all boundaries
it's like it's best pic like i like his
movies but that's like dumb that was a
dumb dumb dumb dumb movie can you
believe it like
it's the only movie i've i've just like
got up and
walked out of the theater
for 15 minutes i was there with like my
family watching it and i was just like
i just took a break
i just i had to like just go out and
take a breath of fresh air because i was
just like
dumb stuff yeah
it was literally but it's so cheesy
i don't know how it got best picture
like why
why anyways um so i guess nightmare
alley is supposed to be as good as that
so
if you thought that was good man
i'm just i'm just sad i'm just sad about
that
and all right what else is on yeah what
else do you want a rose
let's roast oh by the way so last what
is last year like chloe zao one gnome
best director for like nomad land oh
yeah and then goes on to direct the
eternals which is like i don't i haven't
seen the opposite movie it's just like
how like how are you you're not a good
director like like
there's a big budget one
brought up manchester by the sea nomad
lands kind of same thing it's like hey
we have this really established actor
let's just do a film of them looking
that way at the camera yeah slightly off
camera yeah and they're monotone i'm
sure they're thinking about the same
emotional performance the entire yeah
and it's just like it's just about like
the journey you know right there's no
and there is no conclusion manchester by
the sea where is the character
development there is none it's like you
think that's gonna be and then you think
he's gonna get his life together
yeah yeah he [ __ ] does it and then
you're just like what the hell did i do
why did i just watch this
yes but it's real it's like yeah i don't
need to see a movie about a [ __ ]
loser and also offense best actress but
like why isn't the
the the actress jody something or
something from the last duel though she
did a really good job she's not best
actress where where's that where's why
is she not there she had to portray
being like one of the worst experiences
three times in that movie right which i
thought was amazing because like race
has been a very controversial thing to
cover in film like come on this is like
one of those like
three times two different yeah right i
don't know i'm not saying last was like
the best movie ever but like it was
pretty it deserved something it was a
good movie it deserves a nomination it's
like you go to a concert and there's a
pianist who just freaking makes a sweet
song and and it's like
awesome right it's just flawlessly
mozart no but he's
good he can play mozart the best you've
heard
it's best you've heard in a while
it just makes me teo'd
i hear you man there's no easy answer to
this stuff
you know
like spider-man i will be honest i don't
think they had a great pool to choose
from this year i feel like
the level of like cinematic oscar-worthy
movies are just like like the pool is
shrinking and shrinking
now it's like okay
we're taking now the best indie movies
and like we'll skim off the cream of the
crop and put them in the oscars and then
because well because there's nothing in
between to be honest i mean yeah cause
no one's like okay you got your
spiderman
yeah you got spiderman which hey it was
a good movie and it got it got attention
wait hold on but
denis
yeah
i don't know how to get best director
nominated salty i mean the hollywood
does make some cool movies sure but like
there's no doubt about it but it's just
the dog was good it's worth watching i
think it's a good story um and dude the
score in cinematography did that get
nominated for cinematography
what power of the dog is that on there
uh probably a cinematography yeah it's
in every category basically but there's
literally almost nothing in between
5 million and 80 million
what gets produced for that nowadays
like exactly i don't know
i don't know john wick the first john
wick got produced for 75. you know you
know i think they need to finally add
the best blockbuster movie category
since they clearly don't understand how
to like take one of those movies and put
it anywhere else other than vfx
best silver screen masterpiece
yeah
stunts could be an interesting they
should definitely have stunts it's like
they want people to watch the oscars
like maybe you should do that
best blockbuster ads stunts
and now people might be you know
inclined to watch it those acceptance
speeches would be so badass dude they'd
come in like they're imagining scottish
rams
[Music]
and you see like steam pop up behind
stage and dude just like three point
lands hell yeah
that'd be sweet
anyway stunt guys deserve more
recognition but i i have heard the you
know the argument is that
they don't want and this is of course
something that they say is oh you talked
about this already did we
that they don't want to encourage people
doing daredevil [ __ ]
as if they're gonna take cues from the
awesome that's insane
[Music]
that's like that's like when you hear
people say that marijuana is the same as
cocaine it's like
no
you just you're just wrong by that
standard they should stop giving best
actor awards so people stop staring out
at the distance for the whole movie you
know maybe
maybe
keep his weight stable finally
there you go
that's the best response to the stuntman
thing just be like what about christian
bale yeah
he's committing way too hard
is that clinton
invent that oh clinton no that guy was
skinny he's still sick no no no not the
weight thing oh the stairs the staring
off camera without saying anything um
i'm sure there was like a star
film that probably was silent that did
that first
yeah but then like then uh what's his
name gosling did it gosling drive
definitely did that and then uh case not
that case these guys aren't now not
playing badasses but like the the
mysterious
looker yeah the looker there's a looker
and then casey affleck does it now it's
like a thing
all you need to do is stare off while
there's kind of like ambient piano music
yeah yeah and then it cuts from the face
then maybe it's something slowly moving
close-up shot and then it's back to
their face but it's slightly closer from
a different angle angriest actor yeah
and then it's skinniest and it's
cutscene wide angle next day
skinniest and fattest
yeah no i mean look
i think
back to stunts they deserve it i think
stuntmen if anyone knows how to be safe
doing sons it's done then it's literally
the entire job yeah is hiding that is
the merits like if you get hurt you
you're disqualified from the ward like
right that that can be a rule
there you go
i don't know why that wouldn't be a rule
let's do it
is it i just think it's so funny how
there's there's movies that are too
small to be nominated
now and now now finally we're in an age
where there's movies that are too big
to be nominated as well
and they're like come on
it's like i don't want to do an indie a
true indie film it's got to be like one
of those like
like uh nepotism kind of indie films
where it's like okay this isn't it looks
and reads like an indie film but we
totally have a-listers in this yeah and
it's like that's like perfect for oscars
where it's like it embodies the spirit
of an indie film but like truly it's it
is it is like a full-on hollywood
multi-million dollar production indie is
now indy has now by the way shifted and
i'm finding this out entering my film
yeah
this is gonna sound really salty but
it's also the observations
no no i mean like
i i it seems like and i'm hearing this
from a lot of different people
all the big festivals now whereas you
used to be able to enter an indie film
and you know what happened happened now
it's almost like gate kept like if you
don't have an a-list celebrity who like
is taking a pay cut to be in your movie
then you're not going to get into any of
those yeah that's what i'm saying
because it's basically oscar's light
it's like oscars qualifiers now and it's
always kind of been that that's always
been a thing but like it's now that's
just like the official route if you're
in india it's like yeah we're going to
all these film festivals first that's
what that's that's the feeling i get
when i read these like these oscar lists
as of like you know the last few years
it's like these are all just like
like fake faux indie films basically
or it's like it it fee yeah i don't know
they're sadder than your normal film
they're sadder and slower paced
than your average film yeah and there's
less character development make sure
there's far less character development
make sure it's like hey we've got to go
somewhere because someone's dying
and then comes back so we both have to
hop in this tiny little kitchen
around 10 years
but then you part your ways at the end
but there's really no development yeah
it's like you're not gonna be friends
now it's just like
hey remember when we were siblings and
now we're not
yeah or it's like you know yeah it's
like it's like a family drama where it's
like
the dad's trying to
support the family and he does but it's
kind of hard every once in a while
and then it's over right
right
you know those bold creatives
striking ones yeah and it's like tom
cruise really yeah that really like whoa
get to the heart of the human
communication like the real reason we're
all watching is just to like what if tom
cruise was like a normal person like
that's it he's sad
i'd be like that's a good stunt man
that's like sorry
it's just literally tom cruise
we make a movie with him called tom
cruise
the mechanic yeah it's called like he's
a mechanic
and it's just a video it's just 90
minutes of him no you know he'd [ __ ]
kill him
he's like uh we gotta plug this one into
the computer
let's get a readout and see what it's
telling us well it turns out
you need a new radiator yeah no one was
like i can't afford it and he's like
and then by the end of the movie he
replaces it for free yeah and that's
that's the yeah there's like an old lady
who can't afford it because her husband
died and he can't afford it either and
he can't afford it either right but he
still somehow manages to pull together
right yes
yes that's perfect yeah dude that is it
that's it
yeah and we shoot it's a little sepia
tone you know shoot it 21.9 for no
reason not really do anything with the
frame just you shoot it without a choice
where we set the focus for every shot
and then we never change it yeah yeah as
we like do the take we just hold we just
lock focus fix focus sorry and that way
thank you for listening to my favorite
truth podcast we've done in a while have
you guys noticed the like over the
shoulder framing now yeah
movies is like they keep like the
background framed up and then like the
character who's talking
who's framed up is like on the right of
the frame and they're looking off to the
right that's been a thing for a while
it's so annoying it's like i don't want
to look at the out-of-focus background
anyway
this is the saltiest podcast
but you know what sometimes you gotta
get sometimes you gotta get salty thanks
for getting salty with us yeah and uh
if there are any um constructive
asterixes you guys would like to leave
in the comments please feel free we
encourage constructive conversation
around here
you know it balances yeah
yeah any alternative cover treatments
that would be uh
highly recommended as well too
just i'm just curious
just asking for a friend
all right well hey thanks for listening
everybody um this week also actually by
the time this comes out we have just
finished our second week of photography
on son of a dungeon so
huge thanks to everyone on greenlight
who made that possible we are we cannot
wait to get the second season out there
it's gonna be
it's gonna be so much fun it'll be very
shiny and crisp that's right dude this
will be delicious but for your eyes yes
so
i guess on that no
we didn't even have an intro for this
oh
opening theme for the mechanic
yes dude
it's gonna be called shift
car broke down again
[Music]
hey paul this is sherry uh you haven't
returned my call
look
it's just give me the dang child support
check okay like yep
[Music]
it's in the 90s yeah
the 90s of course
no early 2000s like the new 90s
that's the answering machine
daddy where's your car broke down on the
way to school sorry we have to walk
you're a mechanic and you don't even
have a car that works
[Music]
there's like one scene where he does
donuts yeah yeah and he's just like
he's like drinking and doing drinking
doing donuts he's feeling the breeze
feeling what it was like to be alive it
probably hits a deer with this car
that's the last shot and then it goes
it's kind of scary
shift
shift
starring tom cruise he lost
over
100 pounds for this role
oh yeah we forgot to mention
he's
90 pounds
he almost died for this
all role all right see you guys later
thanks for listening
oh